so
hey guys
two minute warning press briefing two
minute warning press briefing thank you
i was just waiting
okay
thank you
you
uh
yes
hi everyone
hello
uh happy friday um so we are joined by
our national security advisor jake
sullivan uh today who will give a brief
uh update uh and then take some
questions from all of you and with that
i will turn it over to jay
good afternoon
thanks everybody for giving me the
opportunity to be here i'd like to make
a few comments
on the situation in russia and ukraine
and then i'd be happy to take your
questions
we continue to to see signs of russian
escalation
including new forces arriving at the
ukrainian border
as we've said before
we are in the window when an invasion
could begin at any time should vladimir
putin decide to order it
i will not comment on the details of our
intelligence information but i do want
to be clear it could begin during the
olympics
despite a lot of speculation
that it would only happen after the
olympics
as we've said before
we are ready either way
we are ready to continue
results-oriented diplomacy that
addresses the security concerns of the
united states russia and europe
consistent with our values and with the
principle of reciprocity
we've continued to make that clear to
russia in close coordination with our
european allies and partners
we are also ready to respond decisively
alongside those allies and partners
should russia choose to take military
action our response would include severe
economic sanctions with similar packages
imposed by the european union the united
kingdom canada and other countries
it would also include changes to nato
and american force posture along the
eastern flank of nato and it would
include continued support to ukraine
the president held a secure video conf
conference today with key allies and
partners to coordinate our approach to
this crisis
the participants were the uk france
germany italy canada poland romania the
secretary general of nato and the
presidents of the european union
we have
achieved a remarkable level of unity and
common purpose
from the broad strategy down to the
technical details
if russia proceeds its long-term power
and influence will be diminished not
enhanced by an invasion
it will face a more determined
transatlantic community
it will have to make more concessions to
china
it will face massive pressure on its
economy and export controls that will
erode its defense industrial base and it
will face a wave of condemnation from
around the world
if on the other hand russia truly seeks
a diplomatic outcome it should not only
say so it should pursue that diplomatic
outcome we are prepared to do that we
have put concrete proposals on the table
they are now out there for the world to
see we're prepared to engage on them and
to discuss the principles and parameters
of european security with our european
partners and with russia
whatever happens next
the west is more united than it's been
in years nato has been strengthened the
alliance is more cohesive more
purposeful more dynamic than at any time
in recent memory
in terms of immediate next steps
president biden and his team will remain
in close contact with our allies and
partners to coordinate both on the
potential for diplomacy and on any
response that is necessary should putin
decide to order military action
we are continuing to reduce the size of
our embassy footprint in kiev
and i now want to take a moment to echo
what both president biden and secretary
blinken have already said we encourage
all american citizens who remain in
ukraine to depart immediately
we want to be crystal clear on this
point
any american in ukraine should leave as
soon as possible and in any event in the
next 24 to 48 hours
we obviously cannot predict the future
we don't know exactly what is going to
happen
but the risk is now high enough
and the threat is now immediate enough
that this is what prudence demands
if you stay
you are assuming
risk
with no guarantee that there will be any
other opportunity to leave
and there no prospect of a u.s military
evacuation in the event of a russian
invasion
if a russian attack on ukraine proceeds
it is likely to begin with aerial
bombing and missile attacks that could
obviously kill civilians without regard
to their nationality
a subsequent ground invasion would
involve the onslaught of a massive force
with virtually no notice communications
to arrange a departure could be severed
and commercial transit halted
no one would be able to count on air or
rail or road departures once military
action
got underway now again i'm not standing
here and saying what is going to happen
or not happen i'm only standing here to
say that the risk is now high enough and
the threat is immediate enough that
prudence demands that it is the time to
leave now while commercial options
and commercial rail and air service
exist while the roads are open
the president will not be putting the
lives of our men and women in uniform at
risk by sending them into a war zone to
rescue people who could have left now
but chose not to so we are asking people
to make the responsible choice with that
i'm happy to take your questions yeah
i know you don't want to get into the
intelligence but can you give us any
sense what has changed over the past 24
or 48 hours to lead to your new level of
concern well first i would say when i uh
appeared on the sunday shows last
weekend i made the point that we were in
the window that russian military action
could begin any day now and that remains
true it could begin any day now and it
could occur
before the olympics have ended i'm not
going to get into intelligence
information but if you look at the
disposition of forces in both belarus
and in russia on the other side of the
ukrainian border from the north from the
east
the russians are in a position to be
able to mount a major military action in
ukraine any day now and for that reason
we believe uh that it is
important for us to communicate to our
allies and partners to the ukrainians
and to the american citizens who are
still there i want to be crystal clear
though we are not saying that a decision
has been taken a final decision has been
taken by president putin what we are
saying is that we have a sufficient
level of concern based on what we are
seeing on the ground and what our
intelligence analysts have picked up uh
that we are sending this clear message
and it remains a message that we have
now been sending for some time and it is
yes it is an urgent message because we
are in an urgent situation to clarify so
you now believe that russia has all the
forces it needs to mount a full-scale
invasion of ukraine what i'm saying is
that russia has all the forces it needs
to conduct a major military action i'm
not sure exactly what you mean by quote
full-scale invasion
but russia could choose
in very short order to commence a major
military action against ukraine yes nato
told the president that it will call up
the nato response force of americans who
have been put on that
short leash and is the president
prepared to send additional unilateral
forces to our partners in
the border region of ukraine and is it
your judgment on the judgment of u.s
intelligence and the u.s government that
putin is behaving as a rational actor in
his judgments at this point
so on the question of the president
authorizing more unilateral u.s forces
to europe he's been clear all along that
he is open to doing so as circumstances
warrant but i want to be very clear
about something these deployments of u.s
service members to poland to romania to
germany
these are not
uh soldiers who are being sent to go
fight russia in ukraine they are not
going to war in ukraine they're not
going to war with russia they're going
to defend
nato territory consistent with our
article 5 obligation they are defensive
deployments they are non-escalatory they
are meant to reinforce reassure and
deter aggression against nato territory
in terms of the u.s forces that have
been put on heightened readiness to be
deployed in the event of a nato decision
to deploy them the president had the
chance as part of the discussion today
to hear from the secretary general no
decisions have been taken in that regard
but those forces stand by should a
decision be taken by the north atlantic
council to call up the nato
response force
and a request comes in for american
forces to be a part of that finally
i can't get inside the head of president
putin i'm not going to speculate as to
his motivations his intentions or at
this point his decisions all i will say
is that we are ready either way if
president putin wants to engage in
diplomacy we are prepared to engage in
diplomacy we would like to find a
diplomatic path forward and we've
sketched out the parameters and
principles for that if president putin
chooses to move forward we will work in
lockstep with our allies and partners to
respond decisively
it sounds like you're saying that the
assessment previously that putin has not
yet made a decision still stands so i
guess based on that is it your
investment that it's more likely that
invasion could happen now than
previously believed
look it's hard to assign uh percentage
probabilities to any of this we
have to think about the range of
scenarios that we confront and it's our
job to be ready for all of them so
what i will say is that the way that he
has built up his forces and put them in
place
along with the other indicators that
that we have collected through
intelligence
makes it clear to us that there is a
very distinct possibility that russia
will choose to act militarily
and there is a reason to believe that
that could happen
uh on a reasonably swift time frame now
we can't pinpoint the day at this point
and we can't pinpoint the hour but what
we can say
is that there is a credible prospect
that a russian military action would
take place even before the end of the
olympics warning that you just delivered
to americans who are in ukraine saying
that they should get out now while they
still can do you have a picture of how
many americans right now are in ukraine
i would refer you to the state
department for the specifics on this
because
i don't want to do it off the top of my
head there's basically two categories
there are those who have registered with
the embassy and those who have not
registered with the embassy in the first
category obviously they have a number
although some of those folks have
already left and didn't deregister in
the second category
we don't know because of course no
american is obligated or required so you
can't fix a perfect number but they're
the ones who are best positioned to be
able to explain what our current picture
is of american citizens in ukraine what
i can do is stand before the world media
and send a very clear message to to all
americans and to any american who's in
ukraine right now who needs help needs
financial help or needs logistical help
to take advantage of a commercial option
to get out please call the u.s embassy
in kyiv because uh we stand ready to
provide that help yes
um the two quick questions one um are
you looking at this being some kind of
attack on keys on the don boss on
another region do you have any sense of
that and then what is the
level of confidence that the
intelligence community has in what
they're hearing about the plan
especially about the potential for it to
come before the end of the military
when you say i'm sorry can you repeat
the second question
the confidence that the intelligence
whether um
this will happen before these events the
intelligence community has sufficient
confidence that i can stand before you
today and say what i have said which is
that there is a distinct possibility
that vladimir putin would order
a military action and invasion of
ukraine
in this window in this time period and
that could include the time period
before february 20th before the beijing
olympics have been completed
and so uh they believe that that
everything i have just said is well
grounded in both what they are seeing on
the ground and and what they are picking
up through all of their various sources
now to your question about what type of
action it would be we've been clear that
it could take a range of different forms
but i want to be equally clear that one
of those forms
is a rapid assault on the city of kiev
that is a possible
line of attack course of action that the
russian forces could choose to take
they could also choose
to move in other parts of ukraine as
well the last point that i would make
and i know this has been the subject of
a fair amount of back and forth between
the administration and the press over
the course of the past week we are
firmly convinced that the russians
should they decide to move forward with
an invasion are looking hard at the
creation of a pretext a false flag
operation something that they generate
and try to blame on the ukrainians as a
trigger for military action and we are
calling that out publicly because uh we
do believe that if russia chooses to do
that they should be held to account the
world should not believe uh that a false
flag operation that they conducted uh is
a legitimate cautious spell eye for
going into ukraine yes thank you thank
you
uh you you mentioned that you do not
want to say uh that putin has made a
decision
but
does the united states believe that the
president pardon me that president putin
has made a decision because pbs newshour
just reported a little bit ago that the
united states does believe that putin
has made a decision and has also
communicated that decision uh to the
russian military is that accurate the
report that you just referenced which i
have not seen yet it does not accurately
capture what the u.s government's view
is today our view is that we do not
believe he has made any kind of final
decision
or we don't know that he has made any
final decision and we have not
communicated that to anybody yes follow
up on that it's just my colleague nick
schifrin who's doing that report he's
citing three western and defense
officials who say the us does believe
that putin has made up his mind has
communicated that to the military and
that they've been shown intelligence on
them you're saying that's not true what
we have communicated to our allies and
partners all 30 allies in nato plus a
range of other partners
our latest intelligence information and
it does not include a statement that uh
vladimir putin has definitively given an
order to proceed with the invasion yes
from your nato allies either i'm sorry
you haven't been shown any evidence or
briefed on intelligence that speaks to
that from nato allies
we've not seen anything come to us that
says a final decision has been taken the
go order has been given what i will say
and the reason i'm up here talking in
the way i am to american citizens the
reason we are taking the various actions
we're taking the reason the president
convened uh our closest allies and
partners from across the nato alliance
in the european union is because we
believe he very well may give the final
go order that is a very distinct
possibility but we are not uh standing
here before you today and say the
order's been given the invasion is on uh
it it may well happen it may well happen
soon uh but we are not saying i think
the way that you've just characterized
that i have not seen this pbs report yet
but as you've characterized it that does
not capture the communication that we
are making to our nato allies nor uh
what we understand internally yes
given the risk that you've laid out the
fact that you're not a 100 certain that
putin has made a decision yet we have
seen other world leaders meeting with
putin has there been any more thought to
president biden engaging with him
directly i would expect that president
biden will uh engage by telephone with
president putin but i don't have
anything to announce for you on that
right now
because this is getting so close now and
the concern that you're you're weighing
towards the american people is there
need to provide some underlying evidence
of just what you're seeing that shows
americans this is a country that went
through iraq and and concerns about what
the intelligence is showing
does the administration see a need to
just provide underlying intelligence
well let me just start with a
fundamental distinction between the
situation in iraq and the situation
today
in the situation in iraq intelligence
was used and deployed from this very
podium to start a war
we are trying to stop a war to prevent a
war to to avert a war and all we can do
is come here before you and give good
faith and share everything that we know
to the best of our ability while
protecting sources and methods so we
continue to get the access to
intelligence we need but there's another
big difference between what happened in
2003 and what's happening in 2022 and
that is in that case
it was information about intentions
about
a hidden thing stuff that couldn't be
seen today we are talking about
more than 100 000 russian troops amassed
along the ukrainian border with every
capacity out there in the open for
people to see it's all over social media
it's all over your news sites so
you can believe your own eyes that the
russians have put in place the
capabilities to conduct a massive
military operation against ukraine
should they choose to do so and then
finally i would just say if you look at
the course of the past few months as we
have said we predict there will be a
buildup of this kind our information is
telling us that the russians are likely
to move in these ways thus far in
november in december and january that
has borne out so i think when you take
all of that together we put forward a
credible case but it's not my job to
stand up here and convince
any of you of anything it's it's your
job to ask the questions and do what you
can do all i can do is based on the best
information i have available that i can
share that the president can share the
secretary of state can share put that
out there uh in close consultation with
our allies and partners that's what
we've done
jake would you expect the country would
hear directly from the president on this
and the risk to world order of vladimir
putin rolling tanks or bombing a foreign
capital well first the country has heard
from the president directly on the
ukraine subject many times over the
course of the past three months and they
will continue to so
uh it's not like
president biden has been silent on this
question he has been very vocal on it he
has spoken to every aspect of it uh he
has read out his calls on it with world
leaders his meetings etc um but he will
continue to speak directly to the
american people as we watch the
situation for any kind of address to the
nation from the oval office no kind of
speech specifically about this issue
with prepared remarks i i don't have
anything to announce in terms of uh
speech or prepared remarks at this point
yeah thank you so much you and other
administration officials have been quite
transparent in describing the strategy
towards ukraine to us the press do you
believe that that strategy is actually
helping uh to reduce tensions or do you
feel that that may be part of the reason
why it's boxing vladimir putin even
further uh in airing your strategy so
publicly like this so uh only one
country has amassed more than a hundred
thousand troops on the border of another
country with all of the capabilities and
capacities to conduct an invasion that
country is russia that country is not
the united states so the fastest way to
de-escalate this situation for all
involved would be for russia to choose
to de-escalate its mobilization of
forces the united states is responding
uh to
the active
sustained buildup of military pressure
on ukraine we are doing so in lockstep
with allies and partners and at the same
time we have been
extremely forward leaning in our
willingness to engage in diplomacy to
address the mutual concerns of russia
the europeans in the united states when
it comes to european security
thank you so much
two questions for you next week vice
president is going to germany for the
munich security conference
why isn't president biden going uh
wouldn't it be a good time to engage
with his allies in person
is he doing enough to avoid a war and
the second question next week the
brazilian president is going to russia
to meet with the vladimir putin uh how
does the white house see this visit and
the timing of this visit and do you guys
expect anything from the brazilian
president during his meeting
if you simply looked at a catalog of the
engagements the president has had with
his allies and partners including the
engagement he had today
that catalog alone would be a rebuttal
to the proposition that he's not doing
enough to rally the west and to offer
russia
a credible diplomatic path out of this
that's included phone calls it's
included meetings it's included video
conferences
it's included
countless sustained effort over the
course of months and we will continue
with that and we're also very proud to
have the vice president representing the
american delegation at the munich
security conference
president
meeting reporting next week
the brazilian president is obviously
you know free to conduct his own
diplomacy with other countries including
with russia and i i really don't have
anything else to add on it today
yes uh thanks dave you mentioned the
possibility of an assault on kiev
specifically what is your sense if putin
does decide to invade ukraine is he
looking to invade and take over the
entire country or a part like premium in
2014. and just one follow-up as well
how do you explain the disconnect
between the rhetoric that we're hearing
or the the warnings we're hearing from
you and other western countries and what
seems to be a playing down
of the risk from ukraine itself
so i i won't speak to the the decisions
that the ukrainian leadership is making
in terms of how they're communicating on
this issue i will only say that we are
coordinating extremely closely with them
president biden has spoken multiple
times with president zielinski i speak
nearly every day uh with senior aides to
president zielinski secretary blinken is
deeply engaged with both his counterpart
and the president and kiev so we will
continue that level of coordination
sharing of information across every
dimension of our government uh but i
can't characterize why it is that
they're choosing their course i can only
say that based on the information we
have we've chosen uh to be uh as
transparent as possible with what we see
as a significant risk of military action
in ukraine
and as to your other question i can't
obviously predict what the exact shape
or scope of the military action will be
as i said before it could take a variety
of forms uh it could be more limited it
could be more expansive
but there are very real possibilities
that it will involve the seizure of a
significant amount of territory in
ukraine and the seizure of major cities
including the capital city
[Music]
the president's departure is at 2 25. so
if people want to leave they need to
leave now if people want to leave they
should leave now we'll proceed
to the departure
do you think that you do you think that
russia thank you sorry i'm just going to
give people a moment to i guess
okay yeah thank you jake
i'll wait until people get up okay
did the u.s wait too long to arm ukraine
especially with respect to weapons that
could defend against an airstrike like
you laid out did they wait too long to
move
u.s forces to nato countries and does
the president still view the idea of
pre-invasion sanctions as a stupid
question
so uh as to the question of waiting too
long on arming the ukrainians
uh over the course of the past year the
united states has provided more than
half a billion dollars 650 million
dollars in defensive assistance to
ukraine that's more than has ever been
given by any president in any year at
any time and that began
more than a year ago under the
presidency of joe biden second we have
made good on the commitment to get those
deliveries into the hands of the
ukrainian armed forces those are
defensive weapons
intended to defend ukraine against
aggression they are not meant for
offensive purposes against any country
so we feel
uh very proud of the contribution and
commitment that we have had to helping
the ukrainians be able to defend
themselves with respect to the question
of the deployment of forces to defend
nato territory our view is that in
addition to the 80 000 strong u.s force
presence in europe today
that's showing in poland and romania in
particular but also through uh the
deployment of air squadrons to the
baltics as we had a few days ago and
other significant moves we've made a
carrier
in the mediterranean that for the first
time in 30 years actually flew the nato
flag as well as the american flag
that we have been forward-leaning and
robust in defending and reassuring our
nato allies and you don't have to take
it from me you can talk to the president
of poland or the president of romania
about the satisfaction they have with
the fact that the united states has
stepped up alongside other nato allies
uh to deter and reassure uh and
reinforce uh our presence along the
eastern flank
is the president looking at sanctions
ahead of an invasion any differently
than he has been up until this point
given the escalation that we're seeing
from russia the president believes that
sanctions are intended to deter
and in order for them to work to deter
they have to be set up in a way where if
putin moves
then the costs are imposed we believe
that that is the right logic
both on its own merits but equally
importantly we believe that the most
important fundamental
for anything that unfolds in this crisis
whether through diplomacy or as a result
of military action is that the west be
strong be united and be determined to
operate with common purpose and he
believes that the sanctions approach
he's taken
in lockstep with our european partners
the canadians and others puts us in a
position for the west to be able to
respond to this contingency in the most
united and purposeful way possible that
will pay dividends for us in this
circumstance but it will also pay
enormous strategic dividends for the
united states in the years and decades
um our understanding is that there was a
sudden meeting last night in the
situation room to talk about russia and
now you and secretary blanken are
obviously using sharper uh rhetoric
about the timing of the invasion i know
you don't want to get into specific
intelligence but is there something that
prompted the meeting last night um and
that has changed the administration's
assessment overnight so i'm not going to
speak to internal deliberations and i'm
not going to get into the specifics of
intelligence information what i am going
to say
is that for some time now including out
of my own very mouth we have been
talking about how we had entered the
window where any day now
uh a military action could be taken that
was the formula i was using several days
ago now
as we gain more information
our view
that
military action could occur any day now
and could occur before the end of the
olympics
is
only growing in terms of its robustness
so that i can stand here and say that is
a very very distinct possibility but i
just want to say two things first we
can't predict
uh the exact
determination that putin would make if
and when he makes a determination so all
we can say
is
that the
the strong possibility of action the
distinct possibility of action in a
relatively near-term time frame um
including along the timeframe that i've
laid out that secretary blinken talked
about that is backed up by our view of
what's happening on the ground and it's
backed up by information that we
continue to acquire
day by day including over the course of
the past few days
why would russia risk provoking china uh
in action during the olympics and
secondly can you just speak more broadly
to the china
russia
is what looks like an emerging alliance
here on certain issues and how much does
that concern you
so i'd say
three things about this first
you know russia's calculus vis-a-vis
china whether they're going to make
beijing upset or not you know that's
kind of between russia and china and
putin will obviously have to decide what
he wants to do on that front china also
has its own decisions to make and to the
extent that they are giving a wink and a
nod or a green light to a russian
invasion of ukraine
for no
justified reason i believe that china
will ultimately come to suffer
consequences as a result of that in the
eyes of the rest of the world most
notably in the eyes of our european
partners and allies and then finally i
would just say that we do not believe
that china can compensate russia for the
economic losses that would be sustained
in the event of an invasion uh due to
sanctions and export controls and the
like just one more thing on the broader
issue of china and russia because there
was quite a bit of hype about the
statement that they put out and it was a
notable statement that we have taken
careful
uh a careful look at
uh i've said this before i want to say
it again and then i'll leave because jen
is now standing up and i think it's it's
well past my time to go the united
states under the biden administration
has confidence
in
us and in the west we are 50 plus of
global gdp china and russia are less
than 20
we have innovation we have
entrepreneurship we have freedom and
when you put all of that together the
the tools and capacities that we can
bring to bear now that we are more
united more purposeful more dynamic than
we have been in a very long time
we are well situated to be able to deal
with any threat or challenge that would
be posed to us by any autocracy in the
world including the two that you just
mentioned so let me just leave
thank you guys
to be clear you can come as long as you
want
i just don't want to get in trouble with
your team when we ask you to come back
the next time
abs absolutely apologize for the
confusion so he's the president's still
in a meeting corrine here is going to
monitor when he gets out of the meeting
when you all need to depart amer or
others if you want to come back sorry we
did not want you to miss the president's
departure but we had a little
miscommunication internally
we yes and he is he is still meeting so
it will not leave without him we have
been assured of that um
okay um i don't have anything at the top
i know you've covered a lot of topics
but i know there's a lot going on in the
world so why don't we go to whatever
else or that that you'd like to discuss
what should we expect this weekend
things have obviously
escalated or moved forward who is the
president going to be talking to
european leaders
what should we expect this weekend this
disposal sure well as you know the
president just spoke with a number of
his european counterparts as well as uh
prime minister trudeau i believe we put
out did we put out have you seen a
readout yet of our
of his call with prime minister trudeau
if not i will give it to you right now
have you seen it yet in your inbox
okay this is what happens when you don't
bring your phone out here so uh here you
go um today uh
prime minister trudeau was obviously
part of the planned meeting as well he
also had a separate meeting with him
where he uh they discussed the ongoing
blockade of key bridges and crossings
between the united states and canada
including detroit windsor sweetwater
coots and pambina emerson the two
leaders agreed that the actions of the
individuals who are obstructing travel
and commerce between our two countries
are having significant direct impacts on
citizens lives and livelihoods the
president expressed his concern that the
united states that united states
companies and workers are experiencing
serious effects including slowdowns in
production shortened work hours and
plant closures the prime minister
promised quick action and enforcing the
law and the president thanked him for
the steps he and other canadian
authorities are taking to restore the
open passage of bridges to the united
states in turn the prime minister also
thanked the president and his
administration the governor of michigan
and u.s officials for all of the
assistance that we have provided to
resolve the disruption and the two
leaders agreed to stay in close touch in
terms of this weekend i just wanted you
to have that component another important
thing happening right now uh in terms of
this weekend as you know the president
will be in camp at camp david uh which
is fully equipped to have engagements of
all sorts including with his including
with his national security team or
european counterparts uh we are making
these decisions about who he'll engage
with on a day-by-day basis we will keep
you all abreast of that as we have done
to date uh but he is uh he'll be at camp
david and i would expect that he'll be
engaged closely with his teams here as
well as his foreign
um
counterparts
court um when will uh president meet
with the senate republicans uh in the
judiciary committee and uh also just a
point of clarification
from the interview with uh lester holt
uh about i believe you said about four
people who's doing the deep dive
uh three and a half four and a half uh
there's no three and a half people
if you could just offer
are we down to uh four uh finalists well
i'm not going to build on what the
president said it is natural that as
this process has proceeded that the list
would be uh come smaller that's a
natural part of the process but
again as he's said many times he is
looking at a range of qualified
individuals strong legal minds
individuals with strong credentials who
have strong character and a dedication
to the rule of law but in terms of the
specific numbers i understand your
question it's natural it'll be
growing smaller but i don't have any
anything to build on to what he said
senate republicans
uh he he will continue to
consult closely with democrats and
republicans that will continue into next
week but i don't have a anything to
preview for you at this point in time go
ahead thanks jen uh the diplomats that
are being moved out of the u.s embassy
in ukraine where are they going are they
going to
other countries are they being taken to
safer locations within
ukraine what can you tell us
it's a great question i'd really refer
you to the state department typically
when we reduce a presence at an embassy
that means they depart the country but i
can certainly check with them and get
you more details on that typically it
means they would return to a home base
what's the administration's current
assessment of putin's strategy in the
black sea is it to cut off ukraine's
naval access
in terms of the exercises i mean our
assessment is that this is a part of
ongoing escalatory actions whether it's
military exercises or the buildup of
more troops
that we have seen at the border in terms
of what it means and what he's preparing
for i would point you to what our
national security advisor just said
which is that you know we continue to
watch closely to assess our role here is
to prepare for a range of
a range of steps he might take but
beyond that i don't have any prediction
of what that means
thanks jen has the u.s shared the latest
intelligence with ukraine and
do does the us feel that ukrainian
government is properly
preparing its citizens for the
possibility of a war because it seems
like they keep downplaying it
well i'm not going to speak for how the
ukrainian officials leaders speak or
engage with their citizens but we do
engage very closely with them sharing of
information as we do with our european
counterparts and that has been the case
at every point in this process is the
state department doing anything right
now to help americans get out of ukraine
or just warning them to get out on their
own
uh well we have been warning for several
weeks now if not longer uh that american
citizens should depart and i think you
heard our national security advisor give
a pretty stark warning of what would
happen on purpose uh what would happen
uh if russia were to invade uh in uh the
difficulty of uh not just uh being in
the middle of a military uh zone but
also the difficulty of departing or
getting out and the fact that departure
means of departure could be cut off and
that was we feel important for american
citizens in ukraine to understand we
have been conveying that if american
citizens don't have the means to depart
that we would provide assistance uh for
those purposes that has been the case
for several weeks now we don't know if
putin has made up his mind why are we
hearing this warning from jake sullivan
that americans should get out ideally
within the next 24 to 48 hours
specifically i don't believe we've heard
that window from him before
because i we recognize that if president
putin were to decide to invade that this
would make it a
a very difficult
circumstance on the ground for american
citizens we don't have an assessment as
he as you heard him say of him making
that decision but he could make that
decision at any point and we want to be
very clear and direct with american
citizens about the risk that uh that
would pose to them that the risk the
risk that would be posed to any civilian
if they remain uh in the country this is
now the second evacuation of americans
um
it's not actually an evacuation to be
clear american citizens can depart
ukraine there are means of departing uh
ukraine this is not a country where we
are at war where we have tens of
thousands of troops who have been
fighting a war for 20 years so it's
incredibly different correct you are
correct in that but we're it's the
second time we've urged american
citizens
to get out of a country actually we've
urged american citizens to depart a
number of times and that is well i think
this but let me finish here because i
think it's important for people to
understand we urged american citizens to
depart kazakhstan we urged american
citizens to depart ethiopia this is a
responsibility that the state department
and our diplomat diplomats who are
serving there and serving around the
world take on to keep american citizens
safe and it may not be front and center
on the news in the united states but
those are conflicts areas and zones
where we are constantly monitoring these
are the two major events that have
happened under this administration and
what does this i would say the people in
ethiopia would differ with that as with
the people in kazakhstan or other parts
of the world where uh there has been
they have been under dangerous
circumstances and they look to the
united states to provide up-to-date
information of their safety and security
in the country the president has
frequently
talked about getting out of afghanistan
as a major event it has impacted his
polling this is a current event that is
underway the question is
what does the administration say to
critics who are looking at these two
events
and questioning this administration's
foreign policy approach who is
questioning us plenty of republicans
like who
i could name off any number of
republicans i'd love to know a name
goodness uh mitch mcconnell
okay well here's what i would say to mr
mcconnell oh the president ended a
20-year war in afghanistan
a war that had cost us thousands of
american lives uh billions trillions of
dollars and was a failed enterprise
after 20 years he was the first
president to do that after many of his
predecessors failed to take exactly that
step uh we knew it would be complicated
we knew it'd be challenging he had the
courage to get our troops out of there
and end a 20-year war this is entirely
different because we are not ending a
20-year war we are trying to prevent war
here we are trying to keep american
citizens safe
in ukraine by encouraging them to depart
by providing them information about what
the security circumstances are on the
ground and i think it's important for
the american public to understand these
significant differences between these
different scenarios go ahead
back to the supreme court for a moment
can you
rule out that the president would be
meeting with any of his
candidates this weekend at camp david
uh here's what i can tell you i i
there's not plans for that but i can
tell you that uh it could be as early as
next week i would not echo uh reporting
that it is definitely next week
given the
heightened
state of uh concern about russia and
ukraine does that at all affect the
timetable for the president on his
supreme court pick simply because of the
time and attention he would need to
devote to that and because senate
democrats were very
upfront saying they're encouraging the
president to move quickly do you sense
that there is an increase in the tempo
for the president to move on his
selection process
we remain on track for the president to
make a decision an announcement on who
he's going to dominate to the supreme
court this month in the next few weeks
that was his intention from the
beginning remains his intention now and
he will continue to read a range of
cases study uh the materials about a
range of candidates that has not been
changed by
whatever decision president putin makes
go ahead
in the nbc interview the president said
he rejected the findings of the
after-action report uh to the state
department that military response to
afghanistan does that mean the president
has ruled out any
action that might be viewed or read as
accountability well steve i think it's
important for people to understand there
was there was no after action report the
washington post report was not an
after-action report uh it was based on a
range of foia documents which is their
right to do uh based on individual
interviews of members of the military
including many who were not a part of
policy making decisions in the situation
room some were many were not but that is
not an after-action report there was
also a report from centcom on the attack
at abby gate on friday which the
president certainly stands by and that
was important work vital work a formal
report and review that was done
internally so i just want to separate
the two for people's understanding uh
what the president was rejecting uh is
the notion that there weren't a range of
preparations done
in advance uh over the course of last
spring and last summer and it's
important to remember that we made the
decision he made the decision to end a
20-year war
he came into office without any plan
well there was a there was a deadline
but without any plan for departure or
for helping the the uh the afghans who
had served by our side for 20 years we
put in place and this is in this is in
these same documents that beginning last
spring a plan a range of contingency
plans should we need to bring american
citizens out or bring afghans out we put
in a place we positioned military troops
on the ground working with department of
defense back in early summer to ensure
that we could execute on that plan and
in every single meeting last august the
president asked the team and often ended
the meeting with this uh is there
anything you need to implement and uh
what your plans are is there anything
you need on the ground he always
ended with that i'd also note that he
always raised uh the question of whether
we needed to evacuate our
embassy uh and people are americans who
are serving in our embassy there that
decision was always posed to the group
at the table that decision was not made
until august 12th so reporting that
suggests otherwise is incorrect uh that
is that that is the state of play that
happened last summer go ahead a question
on inflation since this is the first
time i've heard everything since those
numbers came out um the president has
said the administration is going to
continue to be all hands on deck to try
and bring prices back down uh can you
guess a sense of what that really looks
like because you know you pointed many
times to parts of the buildback better
again that that remains stalled in fact
one of senator manchin's big objections
uh to the bill was the high rate of
inflation so if the buildback better
plan sort of remains at this impasse
what's plan b to try and bring down
these costs well there's a couple steps
that the president is very focused on as
it relates to addressing inflation one i
would note that economists in the
federal reserve still predict that
inflation will come down will moderate
over the course of the year and the
president has also said that he says
this that
an independent body has announced about
calibrating uh over the course of the
coming months and he's obviously
nominated a number of individuals to
fill the board which is an essential
part of addressing this um but i would
also know beyond that how the president
really looks at this as how you're
addressing core costs for the american
people so you reference the build back
better plan first we believe there's a
path forward and the president's going
to continue to fight for it otherwise he
wouldn't have gone to virginia earlier
this week and talked about negotiating
the price of prescription drugs so his
view is that in order to address
costs that have been affecting inflation
but also infecting families for many
decades the cost of prescription drugs
the cost of child care we need to move
that forward but it's not just that we
also need to address supply chains in
the short term at the ports rebuild our
manufacturing infrastructure make sure
that we are implementing the bipartisan
partisan infrastructure
and continuing the press for the
competitiveness legislation that will
help ensure we have funding for chips
for manufacturing of cars here in the
united states and you've also heard
about a fair amount about promoting
competition and that addresses issues
like we've seen price increases in meat
industry and others and that'll help
bring down cost for americans so there
is certainly a significant and important
a
vital role that the federal reserve
plays they are independent he wants that
board to be uh completely filled but
there are a number of uh other steps we
are working to take to lower costs for
the american people just one follow-up
on the question about the embassy yeah
um you've said that you're continuing to
reduce the size of the embassy to be
clear you're not talking about closing
the embassy just yet so what
size are you talking about how much
production here i would really i can
check with the state department it's a
good question but they really have
purview over those numbers and that's uh
that's where we are at the in the
process at this point in time go ahead
and what is the white house with the
reporting that former president trump is
uh still in touch with him
uh well former president trump is not
the president um and we uh president
bayern is the president and he's the one
who conducts diplomacy on behalf of the
united states
one other topic i see that the president
spoke with the prime minister trudeau
about
the blockade
what is um is the white house doing
to help sort of alleviate that the trade
issues that he raised in that call and
more broadly is the white house or is
the government preparing for any kind of
similar um types of demonstrations here
yeah so two different questions so let
me try to answer them both so uh we have
continued obviously the president
speaking with prime minister trudeau
about this as part of our effort but our
team uh list sure what dr lisher would
randle other members of our
administration have been in close touch
with their canadian counterpart parts
over the last few days about how to
address this blockade and the challenge
it is posing to uh the supply chain i
mean fundamentally how we view this is
that the impact of these protests while
we certainly believe in peaceful protest
uh is impacting has the potential to
impact and this is why we are very
focused on this communities workers
being able to travel back and forth
across the bridge who are going to work
who may work on different sides of the
border the ability to get food on the
table to american families to get auto
parts to manufacturers who are trying to
make vehicles so this is whatever their
intended stated purpose is this
effort is is going to have has the
potential to have a huge impact on
workers and the american public but to
go back to your question uh we are in
very close contact with canadian
officials we've also taken steps to help
um uh detour uh routes so that a number
of these trucks can move in different
routes and be able to cross the border
so for example uh while the windsor
detroit ambassador bridge continues to
remain closed port huron is fully
operational customs and border patrol is
rerouting traffic to port huron where
all nine commercial lanes are open the
detroit windsor tunnel is open which is
a way that
individuals who are trying to work on
different sides of the border are able
to travel as well and secretary majors
has also spoken with local officials uh
in affected and potentially affected
states as has secretary buda judge has
been deeply involved with this as well
on your second question um you know we
are um
of course on reports of a similar
freedom convoy i think you're asking
about right in dc event in dc in early
march the department of homeland
security obviously put out a statement
uh on this the other night they're aware
of these reports they're taking all
necessary steps to ensure that the
convoy does not disrupt lawful trade and
transportation or interfere with federal
government and law enforcement
operations on reports that this convoy
is causing disruptions at the super bowl
the department of homeland security or
could i should say the department of
homeland security is surging additional
staff
to its incident command post their
strong cooperation with the california
highway patrol the los angeles police
department and state and local
authorities and the department already
has a lead field coordinator and
emergency operations center in place as
would be standard protocol given this is
a large event the super bowl
and
they will build on that there's already
uh 500 dhs personnel providing extensive
air and maritime security resources so
we are in both close touch with our
canadian counterparts also with local
officials through our department of
homeland security uh our secretary of
transportation is also deeply involved
in this and we're working to address
this on all fronts
thanks jen just to follow up on jeff's
question is it still accurate to say
that the binding administration has not
heard back from the north koreans
despite the outreach correct
and on the conversation that president
biden is expected to have with president
putin is that happening today
i don't have anything to predict in
terms of the timing okay and i think we
have to wrap it up um you wanna do the
last one quick real quick uh well can i
ask on two things yeah well first of all
following up on
what you said earlier confirming that
interviews with supreme court candidates
could begin as early as next week does
he ever find uh how many he wants to
interview is it just a
few you know is there a number that he
has in mind and how long do you expect
that process the interview meeting
process to go just next week or further
well what i can tell you is that the
interview process for any president
typically happens very late in the
process um and uh in terms of the
specific number i'm just not going to
get into that level one more question uh
i'm asking for a colleague regarding his
position on the bankruptcy law for
student loan debt president biden voted
repeatedly as a senator to make it
harder for student loan borrowers for a
raise their debts through bankers
bankruptcy like other secured debts such
as credit cards two years ago as a
presidential campaign he campaigned on
overhauling the bankruptcy law to ease
student debt in addition to his pledge
to forgive ten thousand dollars per
student in federal uh student loans why
hasn't he acted to this point on
bankruptcy law in addition to
the pledge on
debt forgiveness i'm happy to check on
the status of that legislation i don't
know where it is in the process but what
i could reiterate for you is that the
president has forgiven 15 billion
dollars in student loans benefiting more
than 675 000 student loan borrowers uh
since he took office no one has been
required to pay a single dime in federal
student loans and he extended uh the the
um
the hiatus of payment until may to give
people some extra breathing room i'll
check and see the stats of that thank
you thank you
very much
application
pulling the application for the
authorization for the vaccines for under
five is there a white house reaction to
that i know they're going to do a
briefing the fda is so i will leave it
to them to speak to their data thanks
everyone yeah